hello everyone
uh thanks for attending my talk my name
is andrew ewell and i work for a company
called short flow solutions
um and we are a consulting company in
the oil and gas industry and
uh today i'm actually going to be
talking nothing about that i'm going to
be talking about
a side project that i've been working on
for a little less than a year now off
and on
and wanted to share with everyone in the
hopes of kind of getting some more
people involved with it
it is an open source project and what
it's basically looking to do
is to kind of replicate the famous rgg
plot package
in in the wolfram language uh so this
presentation is going to talk a little
bit about some background on
on that package that i just mentioned
and it's gonna talk a little bit about
uh why we need something like this in in
the wolfram language
um and then the bulk of this
presentation i think we'll just be going
through some
some examples of uh things that you can
do with with the r package and where
the current wolfram language package is
in terms of matching some of that
functionality
and then i'll conclude here with just a
few remarks about some of the path
forward
so okay so the the title of my talk is
grammar graphics for the wolfram
language so i wanted to start first with
kind of defining what is the grammar of
graphics um
it was a book written by a famous
statistician i believe
uh that had this that had this title and
ultimately that
uh kind of became one of the the most
famous uh
r uh programming languages packages of
all time which is called ggplot and i'll
talk about that in just a second
so the whole idea of a grammar of
graphics is as opposed to
basically trying to define everything in
your plot up front
you really take more of a layered
approach to defining what
what is what is your graphic actually
made up of um and so you can see i think
this is a good graphic i found
on the internet that kind of describes
that of the what are the various layers
that really go into graphics and
of course you start first with your data
and that's the most kind of fundamental
and most important part of
of what's going to go into a graphics
and then you can start to
change things like aesthetics which is
how how different parts of your data
gets mapped
to the things that the uh the viewer
actually sees in that graphics
um and you can change things like the
scales
uh the geometric objects and then you
can as you get further up in here you
can get more and more
fine in terms of some of the things that
you you can change related to your
graphics
so what are the main advantages of this
approach
so one of them is that really complex
plots
can become very easy to create and
another one is that
creating visualizations because it
becomes a much more
easy process but also a more iterative
process it means that exploring your
data
can can become much easier as well
so i've mentioned ggplot um
so one of the first things i wanted to
start off with is
is this idea of the data set so
in in the r programming language you
know this is a data frame or a table
or you know various other names for it
and and this is kind of a common thing
across a lot of the
data science focus languages of of
having something called a data frame
uh essentially what it is is is your
data set um and your your
observations are rows and your um
columns are
are variables okay so what
what is uh ggplot here's a here's a
really quick example of kind of what the
syntax looks like
uh so you load it with this tidy burst
command here you take this
data set data frame that you've got and
you say i'm going to create
a base plot i'm going to save my
the aesthetics of that plot i'm going to
have my x mapped
to this variable within that data set
called the ispl displacement
and my y is going to be mapped to this
other variable called
hwy which is highway mpg right so that's
going to
describe the first kind of layer of this
of this graphic
and then you're going to say okay and
now that i have those aesthetics defined
i want to create
geom i want to i want to apply a
geometry or
geo geometric objects to those
aesthetics and in this case i'm going to
create points out of that
and so this is really kind of your most
basic xy scatter plot type
type plot here where things kind of get
more interesting and where you can start
to start to see some of the power of
this
approach is in the aesthetics up here
you can you can not only add
you know your x and your y's but you can
also change things
like color so in this case i can map
color to
this variable called class and and then
again with just the geom point
and you get the same xy scatter but this
time you see various colorings
according to the class of the car in
this mpg data set
you can take this another step further
by by basically adding another dimension
to this data set where you can say size
is equal to
this variable uh called cylinders right
and then you get this nice
uh real clear visual of as you increase
the number of cylinders
uh obviously your your highway mpg is
going to go down because you you're
you have more uh more fuel that you're
burning
so i mentioned this before uh you know
data frame is kind of the fundamental
data thing data object that goes into
these into ggplot
and luckily now we have a
a very nice system for that in wolfram
language when uh associations came out
and
and in particular too when when data
sets came out uh so this is kind of the
equivalent of that
uh here in the wolfram language i can
also show that in a data set form
so these are the two data sets that i'll
be working with here in most of these
examples
okay so this this talk is in in no way
trying to diminish the the functionality
and and the built-in visualization
functions in the wolfram language
because they are
uh truly amazing um and and
what they you're able to accomplish with
those um are really impressive
if you are willing to kind of force
yourself
into saying that we are only going to
work with this structured data though
there's a lot of shortcuts that you can
make and a lot of assumptions you can
make that
that can actually i think enhance some
of the capabilities
under the assumption that you're
operating with that that structured data
so as an example
if i wanted to do uh you know just
recreate that list plot
obviously we can do that that scatter
plot obviously we can do that with this
plot
um if i wanted to join that data for
whatever reason
i could obviously add a joined i could
add joined equals true as an option to
list
plot or i have to kind of know ahead of
time hey that's that's a better thing to
do with list line plot
right so it really requires knowing
which function you want up front unless
you want to start diving into some of
the options
as opposed to a grammar or graphics
approach where you've already defined
the x and the y
and and changing your your your geoms is
really just
a single line here of you want a point
or do you want to pass
similarly uh here uh here's another
another example where if i wanted to add
a log
scale here on the y axis uh in the
wolfram language
uh that actually you know is a whole new
symbol it's a it's a list log plot
whereas in a grammar graphics approach
it's just an additional line to change
the scale
kind of at the very end of the graphic
and then lastly i think where where
things um kind of become
a little bit more obvious in terms of um
some of the functionality that we really
want
is when you really have some of these
data sets uh you can do
you know you can do various groupings
and and list plot or list line plot will
do a really good job of handling
uh what what you what you really want to
see with that
by default however if you go to uh
multiple levels or if you wanted to
change something other than
uh the color um or you know things like
the plot markers
or um you know the uh
the plot markers or anything else like
that it starts to become a little bit
more difficult to change some of those
things
by default and you start you start very
quickly writing a lot of
kind of ad hoc code to get some of that
accomplished
additionally here so if i wanted to take
that that xy
data and add a linear line to it just
fit the data to a linear line and add
that
actually into this graphic one of the
ways i can do that is with this epilogue
statement
which is not super complicated but you
know these kinds of things again can
start to add up as
as you create really complex graphics
and if you're in an exploratory
data phase really what you want is to be
able to do these things kind of quickly
and then lastly i kind of use this as an
example i see a lot of these kinds of
plots and sometimes i have to make them
myself
and it's really it's it's kind of a bar
plot um but you
you really want to show it with points
instead and then you can start to add
different uncertainty bands on here
and so just creating these kinds of
plots where one of your axes labels are
really
text is something i found more difficult
to do with some of the standard
functions that are that are built into
the language right now
okay so ggplot as i mentioned this is a
entirely wolfram language open source
project that i've been working on
um i actually have not have not touched
it here in a couple of months but i was
working on it pretty extensively towards
the beginning of the year
um and it's it's in a proper paclet
distribution so you can install it
really easily from github
and i'll mention some of that here at
the end so the overall syntax so i've
tried to make this as
compatible with with the way things kind
of work in the r world because there's
some there's some good ideas there
while kind of maintaining uh the wolfram
language-esque
type syntax that that people would be
accustomed to uh so the standard kind of
input for this
is gg plot your data set
some of your maybe initial aesthetics
like x and y and then any other
additional aesthetics and genomes that
you might have
the other way you can do this is kind of
fully
specify what your data is which is which
is this data set
um you can do your additional aesthetics
and geoms there
i personally use operator forms quite a
bit
in when i'm working in wolfram language
and i think it makes for more readable
code
so i've tried to make that as supported
as possible so you can say for example
here's my data set
and i just want to pass in you know all
the
you know aesthetics and geoms and things
like that and this is actually a more
kind of typical approach that you would
you would do
with r as well so it keeps keeps the the
code reading
uh very consistent between the two there
things can also get
a little bit more complicated if you'd
like you can define
a lot of these options like the data and
the aesthetics for
individual geoms and kind of mix and
match those
uh however you want uh and then lastly
uh there's an options any of the kind of
options you might want to be able to
tweak within the graphics you can you
can pass those in
as well things like frame label or plot
range or
even epilogue or things like those are
supported as well
okay so uh here's kind of a basic plot
so this is as i mentioned with the
syntax i'm using this mpg data set
i'm saying x i want to map to the displ
variable y to highway and then i'm going
to add a geom point to it
so this is just kind of recreating some
of those basic plots that i showed
originally with
with the r package uh here again is just
to emphasize that
operator form uh which is actually how i
mentioned i like to use
to use this most often
so some of the more advanced cases here
all right so
again recreating recreating those same
examples i used before so
in this case now i want to add uh color
as as another indicator here and i'm
going to map that to
the the variable of class and then add
geom points to that
and then finally to kind of get a you
know a fourth dimension in here i can
say size i want to map that to
cylinders again
um okay so where where uh other things
start to get a little bit more
interesting is
as i mentioned um before you know adding
things like a linear line or something
like that to
to a plot is it takes a lot of ad hoc
code but under this grammar graphics
approach
you can you can define these aesthetics
and then adding additional genomes is
really just a
uh something you can do very easily by
just appending them
uh to the function here
so this in this case i have a linear
line now uh that fits that data
and then also um you know if i want to
break my data down still by that uh
by the number of cylinders uh because
these are these are
uh aesthetics um i could still add you
know geom points um and the colors will
will break down according to the number
of cylinders and then this geom smooth
will also apply
uh based on the number of colors so
things can start to get
pretty complicated pretty quickly here
but you can see some of the
some of the power that this type of
approach gives you
if i wanted to do this instead with an
epilogue
right you're you're you have to start
breaking this data down yourself into
the groups and then doing linear fits on
all three of these data sets and uh the
code for that would become
would become quite large
uh so similarly i mentioned uh changing
scales in in the our
our example uh so here uh
just ignore this uh two here at the end
this is this is not a log two it's
a log ten i i have some other symbols to
find in another package
uh and i needed to keep those preserved
so i just added two
here to these numbers that are to the to
these symbols but but you can ignore
that so
uh so here if i wanted to add uh you
know
a log scale here on my y-axis i can do
that really easily
by just adding this this keyword
similarly if i wanted to do it
to both the x and the y axis i can do
that also really easily
and then here this is a different data
set not the mbg data set
but one of my uh one of my values in
here
is this date uh which are actual date
objects um and so
if i go to plot this as is uh those date
objects get turned into
absolute time by default and so things
look a little weird uh but i have an
option in here that you can say
uh scale scale your accessory x axis
based on date
and uh and everything will kind of work
itself out that way
okay so some uh some of the uh more
advanced
uh use cases so i mentioned i mentioned
this as an example
is you know sometimes you want to have
uh basically what's a bar chart
you want you know x you want uh text to
be
on you know some axes which which kind
of defaults you to using something like
a bar chart
but really if you wanted something more
like points instead of bars
you know sometimes i sometimes things
like that can be more difficult to do
so in this grammar graphics approach
instead
i have some some cleanup code here where
i'm calculating
uh the median of each uh of each of
these different classes of car
but the real code here to generate this
plot is again i'm just mapping
my x to to highway my y
to this text label of classes and then
i'm applying a geom point to it
some of the things that i'm starting
starting to implement
are things like histograms or or actual
column charts um some of those things
are not as
smoothed out as some of the line and
point related geomets though
but but histograms are are supported as
well
right now and then some some really neat
things i i like
um i like to use a lot so if i were to
uh you know plot how does your city
mpg uh change you know correlate to
to your highway um you know something
that's really nice to add and this is
not hard to do with an epilogue
at all but just just add a parody line
in there
and you can do something like that
really easily with uh with just adding
another geom here
and then similarly you can add a
vertical line
geom or a horizontal line geom specify
your x and y intercepts
and kind of the rest is taken care of
for you
so just kind of where it's at right now
so these are the
the geom's that that are kind of been
been looked at the most and
been incorporated into the package uh
points lines
paths which are essentially lines that
have your x-axis data
sorted uh you know smooth which are
you know the linear lines that i showed
before there's really only linear lines
are supported right now no
no kind of advanced uh regression models
or anything
and then the parity lines and and
horizontal and vertical lines
um there are there are tons more that uh
that could and probably should be
developed
into this and i'll talk about that here
at the end
and then in terms of the scale uh again
please ignore the twos here at the end
but
uh you know you can have a linear scales
on your x and y log
and and date um for for both x and y
axes
okay so yeah i'm missing functions so if
you notice
uh in some of the r plots everything
that you do
you know kind of by default you get a
very nice legend and that's also
something that all the
you know default wolfram language
functions support especially when you're
working with
like data sets in particular so that
that is something that obviously needs
needs to be added and and something i
i'd like to tackle at some point
uh i mentioned this um the list of
genomes is pretty small right now
i focus just on on points and lines
because those are things that i tend to
plot the most when i'm analyzing some of
my own data but this list could get
quite long and i hope that it would i
think there's a lot of
geom's that are supported in something
like ggplot that allows you to really
make
really complicated and nice looking
visuals pretty easily
so that would be nice to get to at some
point
fastening this was really something i
hadn't mentioned
in the original r kind of
examples but this is really how you add
an additional dimension
to your data so when you've kind of
maxed out on things like you know
specifying the colors
or the plot markers or the size of the
plot markers uh one of the last things
you can do is is to fasten the data
or fasten wrap the data and what that
does is it'll create an individual plot
for each of the
data sets however you've broken it down
um and the nice thing here is you know
if
by default these axes are all conserved
in terms of their plot range
so it allows for comparisons to be done
really easily
and we have there's some nice language
nice support for this uh
now and in some of the newer versions of
wolfram language with um
graphics grid and graphics column and
things like that so i think some of this
functionality could be
could be much much easier to implement
with some of those new functions as well
the other nice thing that that ggpot in
in the r world
supports is you know you can not only
map
you know your some of these aesthetics
to to uh just the raw variables but you
can include all
any kinds of arbitrary functions so like
in this case if i just really wanted to
highlight
you know where is my highway mpg uh less
than 20 you know something like that is
really easy to do
uh with the with the r package and i
don't have any kind of support for that
yet but um i think it could be something
that could be done um
somewhat easily with with um with the
code base right now
and then just just kind of lastly i
think general robustness right if um
as i start to use this i i run into
issues and i think you know there's a
lot of things that that can be improved
for sure and there's a lot of scenarios
where
uh i i think we're i'm probably not
making the right
uh default behavior in terms of what was
the right default decision in terms of
what the right behavior should be
and i think there's some interesting uh
scenarios where where some of that can
really be improved quite a bit
so lastly i'll just conclude um i i
watched um steven's keynote last night
and i think one of the things he
mentioned was um you know getting
you know getting more uh open source
packages
available and and and getting more
people to work on some of those things
um so this
is this is an open source project
i'm the only one that's that's worked on
it right now but uh
i would i really like to um
uh i would really love to have other
people kind of uh
help support this um you know other
people being you know
well from staff because i i'm sure that
um
they would probably look at some of the
code and immediately know ways of kind
of improving things that are that are
that are being done and as well as you
know academic and business uh
uh people as well i think there's a real
opportunity for us to uh
create something that's uh equally as
good as what gg plot can provide
uh with something like this and and uh i
think
you know it makes sense that something
like this would never really exist
in you know in the standard wolfram
language i think it's it's kind of
perfect for something as an open source
package that you can kind of add into
the language
so uh here is my uh github
you know a l89 the repository is ggplot
and that's that's
the full path um and uh you know please
if uh if something like this interests
you uh let me know and
and hopefully there's ways we can get
other people involved in it
so that is the the end of my
presentation um i
will uh quickly jump over here and see
if um
there are any questions uh yeah there's
a question are you using graphics under
the hood
yes um so they're the graphics language
uh within wolfram is incredibly
impressive
and if you're kind of able to navigate
your way through the really fundamental
syntax there things like you know the
graphics primitives and lines and things
like that
that's that's really the right way to go
i spent some initial time
uh when i was developing this trying to
see if uh you know
figuring out ahead of time if list plot
or this line plot or bar chart were the
right things to use and
and and they really got messy really
quickly so if you can go more
fundamental
than that and and work at the graphics
level itself using primitives
i found it to be a much better way to do
it
um yeah and there's a second question i
think kind of um related to that
um so yeah it i i am as i mentioned
using
using primitives as much as possible
and there is no there is no r code being
being called here this is
entirely written in wolfram language yes
the the packlet is available
um it should be on github if you go to
that um
go to that that site that i that um
repository that i
that i mentioned and actually now that
i'm now that i'm looking at that i may
not have
uh actually pushed the paclet so i will
do that um
this afternoon but please yeah look at
the the repository
on github and i'll make the the actual
packlet itself available there so
so you can easily install this uh
there's a question about is the our
source
useful i i've spent some time looking at
it
i'm i am not a very good r
programmer so i tend to spend a lot of
time trying to figure out what's going
on
um i think i think it it probably would
be pretty useful to someone that can
they can really read it really
efficiently i found myself kind of
uh coding this up myself in wolfram
language as i go as opposed to trying to
recode up whatever was in what is
whatever is in the r package
okay if there are no more questions i'll
go ahead and
stop this now thanks thanks again
everyone